Descartes breaks this book to passions
of the soul in part to address some of
the gaps in his philosophy by the time
of the rites as he's well established
these were the meditations the the
discourse on method which was appended
to a bunch of other words and mentions
his optics in here and that was one of
the works that
he's got a well worked out idea of how
the mind and body work and how they
connect with each other but he hasn't
laid out some parts of it and one thing
that you find in systemic philosophy is
treatments of the emotions what's going
on when we deal this not just like you
know feel things like I'm feeling you
know touching myself here or if I do
this you know really hard and feel a
sense of pain what's going on when I
feel sadness or happiness or anger or
desire things like that the stuff that
makes us tick our emotions are
incredibly important part of ourselves
what I'm going to be doing in large part
with the board today and sort of
sketching out a model of the human being
and how parts of us interact with other
parts so decart starts out by thinking
in terms of the human being as being a
union of two things
body and
soul or that you live in Vegas over a
little better maybe more comfortable
with this term of mine how do the mind
and the body connect up together because
clearly they're not exactly the same
thing
you're a perception of sight you know
think about what you remember from
whenever you learn its biology health
class maybe other classes that you took
what's going on when you actually see
things life is coming into your eyes
yeah and what's happening that oh just
go like straight from your eyes into
your brain that's part of what's going
on there's like flips taking place you
know
the eyeballs are connected by this big
thick set of nerves that goes into the
brain it's pretty complicated the eye
itself is pretty complicated so all
these rods and cones and already be
colorblind in any way red green or
whatever the other kinds are if you were
but that is is some of the things in
your eyes I forget whether it's the rods
or calls aren't distinguishing things
the way they want to they're not picking
up on certain signals coming in from the
environment any of you have trouble with
night vision video should probably eat
carrots you know that helps you out you
get a little bit older night vision
starts to go that's a matter of the
physiology of the eye and then it gets
transmitted into electrical impulses
through this nerve and it goes into the
brain and your brain we know now is way
more complicated than they cart thought
it was because you know decart is
working with the science of his time we
now know it's composed of these special
cells what do they call the remember
sort of an end
yeah there are islands and you ever look
at one of those really kind of hideous
things you know all sorts of little
tubes going off in different directions
but but those have a function right what
do they transmit this is what they Kurt
didn't understand because he thought it
was in terms of animal spirits nobody
nobody talks about adjusting your animal
spirit balance these days right
electricity
your brain is is full of electrical
impulses and these neurons connect up
with each other in complicated ways in
ways that we're still trying to figure
out now all of that stuff being there
and any happening is anyone's like to
see you know take for instance that that
hat three four colors right red white
light blue and dark blue are there like
little red neurons that are being
triggered inside of your head and then
you know when that switch flips a sends
red and inside your head that's not
really like that the perception that you
have is something mental that you
experience what's going on in your mind
is something different than what's going
on in your body they're connected up
with each other the body does in fact
act on the mind you're hearing my voice
right now sound waves are hitting your
ears your ears are going through this
whole long you know it's difficult to
describe process and those electrical
impulses are shooting up through your
nerves not very far cause you know the
right on the side of your head into your
brain your brain is you know doing a few
things with those to process those and
your mind registers that it's sound does
your brain register that is a human
voice that is communicating
meaning maybe to a certain extent it
plays a role in that but where do you
actually understand the meaning of my
words with your mind not just with your
brain with your mind
and you know you can have special what
the hell is that how does it have work
and Descartes student willing to say you
know we observe this we don't really at
bottom know exactly what it is but but
we know that we have this now think
about this does your mind affect your
body too can you think about doing
something and then do it like come to
class or you know jump up and down over
work out things like that yeah your your
mind can tell your body would do is your
mind also is able to do something
different which is to reflect upon
itself and of course your body can do
things piss off canta like what happens
when you don't eat enough if any of you
ever had to fast for one reason or
another or you've done hungry because
you know you screwed something up and
you don't have a launch ticket at launch
or forgot to pack a launch or it's a
crisis and you can't eat for you know a
day or two or something like that
what was your body's are feeling like
that
what's it like to be hungry really not
just like what they call mouth hungry
where use your board and you want
something to stick in your mouth yeah
sore okay yeah
then how many have felt hunger Kings
they call them that pains hunger pangs
that like in here you actually it hurts
a bit you start feeling lethargic it's
hard to concentrate the irritable of
people these are all phenomenal effects
of hunger and something's going on in
your body your body is sending you no
signals not just your mind but to other
parts your boss feed us or we're gonna
die not right away but sooner or later
so get some food in us as soon as you
can what happens when you're scared
something startles you like you know for
example we were joking around the
beginning of class about spider does a
scary thing spider dropping down right
in front of you like when you're trying
to drink water right in front of your
face now imagine that and you know this
metaphor like for for a second it was as
big as the Tyrannosaurus Rex what does
it actually mean obviously you didn't
think it was as big as a Tyrannosaurus
Rex yeah perspective you're right there
many things do look bigger when you're
when you're closer to them but what
happens to your body when you have that
for your response what goes up what do
you experience
that's that and pain oh you can whip it
okay so what is it what is that like
what does panic look like I feel like
yeah that's a big part of it now notice
we can talk about what it feels like to
have an adrenaline rush that's really a
physical phenomenon isn't because
adrenaline is a it's not a hormone right
what is it
does anyone know offhand exactly what
kind of chemical it is that goes in your
system that starts kicking other things
into gear when you have an adrenaline
spike what else happens to your body
would have to your heart starts racing
not just beating faster but raising this
is why they use adrenaline to provide
people up your overdoses get their heart
sorted and also used for the nerve agent
poisoning guys in the army they still do
that all that nerve agent like you know
training you know what to do with the
auto-injector
well they should because it's important
one of the things they they're gonna
teach you is how to inject yourself with
adrenaline so that you keep yourself
from dying
you know after you inject yourself but
the other thing that neutralizes a nerve
agent which also screws you up a bit to
people who have done it
see
so adrenaline what else happens with an
adrenaline the blood of your body heart
starts racing anything else you have to
do I get the shakes yeah okay so what
does that mean that special things that
your body is primed yet to do faster
movements the muscles can twitch faster
you're not gonna be like Hulk strong
most likely you know but people do
amazing things under the influence of
adrenaline and then afterwards they they
crash thank you body can't sustain that
yeah what's going on there is things
that you are sensing mentally
perceptions that you are having about
what's going on with your body and part
of it is sort of subterranean it's just
going on in your body you're not
observing your heart beating faster but
you can feel the effects of it so these
are all good examples of how that
interplay works here and there gonna be
a lot of back and forth you see the
spider that's a physical action it goes
into your brain and it processes it it
says holy crap this is gonna fight me
and then you know if that produces a
physical reaction and then you know you
say wow I don't like the way this feels
the physical reaction I better get
myself under control I start doing some
breathing exercises there's a whole
possible cycle here of interacting
between the mind and the body but it's
very important to be able to distinguish
between blessing between the two of them
in order to understand how these work
together so they Kirk thinks of this in
terms of we called passion and passion
is an old-fashioned term that means
being acted upon so when you are having
a passion of the soul something is
acting where out of the mind something
is acting upon the mind and this could
work one of two ways because what what
can
act of mine the body can act on the mind
and it could be that something is acting
on the body from the outside like when
you're hearing my voice I'm speaking I'm
producing sound waves you're taking
those in through your body through your
ears actually the nerves and then that
is going to your mind so in a way I'm
acting on you but it's really I'm acting
on your body which is then acting on
your mind so that's a passion the mind
can also act upon itself right for
example what I'd like you to do right
now is imagine a orange turkey since
Thanksgiving is coming up everyone doing
that probably you know picture like a
turkey looking thing you just plop the
color orange I now imagine I'll be like
eating turkey at Thanksgiving and also a
few of your vegetarians imagine tofu in
that case something similar now I'm
agent orange flavored like with orange
rind
can you imagine that can you make
yourself think that can you sort of
almost smell the orange rind
you know what's going on there is your
mind is actually making itself do
something that was through your own will
your own choice whenever you make your
mind do something that you want to do or
you're following instructions that you
want to follow to do to set screw you
dr. Stadler but you're not going to make
me think of Turkey or something like
that or I hate orange you're not going
to make me think of orange whatever
you're doing something like that
you are acting upon yourself you are
both active and ham
at the same time Descartes says we're
not going to call those passions because
you are all you are active at the same
time so what are we going to call the
passions of the soul it's going to be
the stuff that has to do with the body
acting on the soul of the mind but not
every way in which the body is acting on
the soul of the mind because we have
some things that we don't want to you
know confuse with emotions like you
hearing me right now is not an emotion
right you know
you know say did a psychotic there's no
way you could like possibly make it here
embarrassed if you were actually
psychotic as well what we call emotions
have to do with a certain way in which
the body react the mind not perceptions
non-campus that have been established in
the body not memory which is actually
the mind working on its side but
feelings so that's what we're going to
be looking at with this entire work yeah
I'm gonna skip through quite a bit of
the text because some of it is not
particularly useful for you anymore
unless you have a you know curiosity
about ancient medicine or stuff like
that
nobody believes that the heart works the
way that Descartes was thinking that it
worked and you know it's caring heeds or
anything like that nobody believes any
animal spirits anymore and we don't even
believe that there's like a little part
of the brain that kind of bounces from
side to side and that's where the mind
of the body interact we have to
supplement that with a better way of
understanding the mind-body interaction
but there's a lot in here that that we
do want to look
as far as eight cards model because the
cuts model is a very attractive one if
you want to think that you have it in
mind distinct from your body or your
brain if you want to think that your
consciousness is not just a matter of
brain chemistry and electrical impulses
then this might be more attractive to
you but then you want to figure out well
how do these things actually work with
each other so I'm going to skip over all
this stuff about how you know organs
work and all of that and the spirits and
I'm going to skip all the way to head to
the soles functions
section 17 he says now that we've looked
at all the things the body can do
unaided its body by itself it's easy for
us to see there's nothing in us that we
must attribute to our soul except their
thoughts there's two main kinds of
thoughts actions of the soul like
remembering willing thinking in passions
of the soul the ones I call the actions
are all our politians all the things
that we will when you decide that you
want to think about something you are
actually choosing to think about part of
your your mind is your your will and
when you decide to sleep in that's you
choosing to sleep in when you decide to
get your butt out of bed that's you
choose you to do that do you love the
snooze go to times but not three because
three would mean that you're a layabout
and two is eight okay that's you
choosing since on the other hand their
various perceptions or items of
knowledge can be called the souls
passions in a general sense
so perceptions but also feelings by
coming in from the outside and he talks
about the will all I want to emphasize
here is that the will those come from
the mind to the body everyone raise your
hand right now you just acted with your
will
and you have to Don your body now think
about raising your hand now are you just
acted by using the web easy enough to
get perceptions what are perceptions
since things are coming in some of the
perceptions that we have are actually
coming through a sense organs some of
them are internal to us like when you
feel hunger in your body it's not like
your skin has involved somehow or your
eyes are you're actually have internal
perceptions as well right we also have
imagination imagination was taking place
on the minus part that's taking images
that you've stored up from your
experiences you know again here's the
spider thing the fact that you could
actually like say big as a Tyrannosaurus
Rex you guys they have some imagination
of the Tyrannosaurus Rex
and for any of you to make sense of that
you have to have some memory of
something connected with dinosaurs right
so your mind is doing that stuff all the
time
now tinker talks about some imaginings
being caused solely by the body here's
where it gets got interesting so we have
the body and the soul where do they
actually hooked up together
where do we
there's no company of a lady the mind is
in your belly good man
some people can I think that yeah
exactly so our view and the current view
are pretty similar
you notice really rejects another view
that says that it's the heart the
physical heart where you know emotions
are taking place or perceptions are
taking place you know people were kind
of hazy about this for a while
Aristotle actually and this is going
back to millennia right Aristotle didn't
really know what the brain did thought
it was kind of like a cooling system
because you know if you look at it and
you look at like a radiator not that
they had radiators back then it kind of
looks sort of like that that kind of
function he didn't actually realize that
the brain was so important by the curt's
time they did they have weird ideas
about animal spirits and you know
Springs and pulleys and stuff like that
we know that that's not the case but he
was onto something the brain sends
impulses and so that means that what's
going on at the brain is really
important does the brain do stuff on its
own can it can it produce imagination of
things without you choosing to do it
without you willing to do it no not at
all
what happens when you dream are you
choosing your dreams I know I'm not
because if I did I choose a hell of a
lot better dreams rather than puzzling
things that I wake up from
and think there must have been some
meaning to it they figured it out you
know and when you wake up from a good
dream would you say that was a good
dream I'm gonna go back and dream that
dream some more does that work don't
work for any of you know if it does let
me know how to do it because I would you
know I would do that I have good dreams
occasionally that I'd like to revisit
what about bad dreams do you control
whether you have a nightmare or not to
some degree I mean don't watch a horror
movie right before you go to bed that
probably helps hey see your brain does
do some things on its own does your
brain ever do things in your waking life
that produce things in your buying maybe
imaginations maybe feelings that you
didn't choose
sure that's why people get depressed you
know you can say to something oh snap
out of it just will yourself not to be
depressed that doesn't work I mean you
know if you do certain things that will
help you out but you might actually the
chemical imbalance in your brain that's
going on that's where medication might
help that's why we did people
antidepressants at least some of the
time sometimes we actually just give
them to get people out of the office but
some people actually need them you know
similarly some people need anti-anxiety
medication interestingly some of these
things can be used for multiple things
wellbutrin can be used to help people
quit smoking
let us package it under a different name
and give it a different color something
that's sexy
all right so the brain is really
important what's going out of the brain
can affect what's going out of the body
and here's where we want to buy into the
curt's viewpoint about the brain a
little bit just so that we can get off
the tarmac sorcery we're skipping ahead
a little bit this is to a part 25 ways
as the perceptions we relate to our soul
so perceptions that we relate to our
soul are those who affects we feel as
being in the soul itself
you notice I'm always like doing this
did we do this metaphorical body thing
about there like maybe the soul is here
or something like that really I should
be doing this because the brain is the
adjoint but I mean you could do it
anywhere you want because the soul is
sort of equally spread throughout the
body the card size it's connected with
the entire body there are some things
you feel in the soul and you don't feel
in the brain of the body particularly
they're caused by what's going out of
the brain and there are certain effects
that happen with the body and those are
passions those are emotions he says
these include the feelings of joy anger
and the like which are arousing us
sometimes by the objects that stimulate
our nerves sometimes also by the good
causes now all of our perceptions are he
says indeed passions with respect to our
soul but we want to restrict the term
passion to signify only perceptions that
relate to the soul itself so what would
these people now he gives you a
definition in the section 27 he actually
titles that definitions definition of
passions of the soul he says yeah they
considered how the passions of the soul
differ from its other thoughts it seems
to me we can define them generally as
perception sensations or commotions of
the soul that tells you what kind of
thing they all right
perceptions sensations or commotions of
the soul which not here's a
differentiation of definition we relate
particularly to the soul not to things
outside of us but to the soul and our
cause maintained and strengthened by
some movement of the spirits the animal
spirits so the cart thinks that the body
and the brain are connected through the
nerves you know and what the nerves do
is transmit the animal spirits to
different parts of the body
you know the muscles to make them
contract to spam to the eyes you know to
have them to get information to look
around a thing to the heart the liver
the spleen all these other things right
we have a similar idea of the body the
brain is sort of at the top it runs the
show and what's going on the nerves it's
not animal spirits but electrical
impulses your heart is beating because
your brain is telling it to be it's not
going to keep beating a few different
brain ISM some part of your brain
doesn't keep
to do that that's electrical impulses
that's why the pacemaker can you know be
implanted and it can make it beep that's
why if you take somebody's heart out you
could and you're disconnected from the
brain you could still make it beep by it
by giving electrical impulses right so
get rid of the animal spirits notion and
substitute in their passions are related
particularly to the soul and our cause
maintained and strengthened by some
action of the brain with the body that
make more sense your body is this very
complicated machine the brain is sort of
like the control center it works through
electrical impulses also through
hormones things along those lines so the
passions of the soul the emotions that
you feel our felt particularly here
they're not like perceptions where you
say you know perceive this piece of
chalk right now there's an external
object that your your eyes are tracking
your anger is inside of you your joy is
inside of you it can be caused by
external things but it's not like a
perception where it relates to the
external thing that way does that make
sense this is something important to
grasp so everyone everyone ok so he
gives you an explanation or he says I'm
gonna skip over the first part e says I
add they relate particularly to the soul
to distinguish them from sensations of
external objects or to sensations within
our body like hunger pain there cause
maintain is strengthened by some women
of the the spirits who are in our case
electrical impulses to distinguish them
from things
choose things that we will again you
can't will to make yourself happy sad
angry directly you can will to think
about things that will make you angry to
think about things that will make you
sad but that's not the same thing as
like willing that feeling directly I'm
gonna skip over like the soul and unite
all the parts and i'ma skip over the
thing about the pineal gland the mice
any of you are particularly interested
in that
take her here's the law in order
Descartes thought there's a little part
of the brain and it's the one part that
you know it's not you've got two
hemispheres of the brain and both of the
hemispheres going to look like they have
more or less the same equipment so you
know they must be for you know equal
parts the body or something like that
there's one part of the brain that's
just all by itself
this little pineal gland and the current
thought of it is getting moved by the
animal spirits in different ways think
of a joystick or or a controller alright
for a video game and now imagine that
that that joystick can make everything
on the screen happen which is the case
right and it really is much more like a
joystick than you know a complicated
controller with buttons and stuff like
that because all it does is kind of
bounce around
I suppose it takes out different
configurations as well as if you pushed
it in this part wishing that part so
maybe it is more like a controller with
a couple buttons now those of you who
play video games think about all the
different things you can get to happen
in that game by use of those very simple
commands by doing different combinations
of them right it's quite a few things I
think about fighting games like
first-person shooter games right
go forward backwards go side-to-side
how do you duck usually jump how do you
gonna access your inventory probably
another button right there why a lot of
them use keyboards there's not that much
that you can do though it's very
difficult to see just how this is
supposed to work in real life in de
cartes account one essentially joystick
or controller is supposed to get all of
that information to the brain I mean
just look around this room for a first
everyone look at all of your classmates
clothing all the different colors all
the different shapes sizes the way
things are worn your brain is like
processing that this is this is an easy
task for your brain to get compared to
some of the things that it does
routinely this is simple stuff
could that really be done by just this
little gland bouncing around probably
not
could it be done by a massive computer
stored away in your skull that has
literally millions connected parts that
can actually rewire itself grow replace
parts that have gotten damaged and
interact with all the rest of the body
through electrical impulses hormones and
various other mechanisms probably that's
probably big enough to get over this
task of like looking around and noticing
what everybody's wearing what color as
it is that's what's involved when you're
feeling things
your feelings are caused by what's going
on in your brain and how your mind takes
in the interaction with your brain so
when you're feeling sad something is
happening and indeed that you're
bringing something there's a physical
aspect to sadness and then it goes into
the rest your body when you're feeling
happy similarly when you're feeling
angry when you're feeling surprised but
if you like discussed it all these sorts
of things are happening both in your
brain where electrical impulses are
firing and all sorts of cool stuff is
going on and we can look at your MRI
machines and you this is more what you
are you are actually feeling the emotion
it's cause because you're your body your
soul are united to each other
I suppose you know if you believe the
cart doesn't really talk about this this
much but if you believe that the soul
will survive after death the only way
that it could feel something like
emotions would be reawakened
memory and they they wouldn't be that
strong they would be like what he called
shadows or imaginings so I'm gonna skip
over the pineal gland thing let's get to
discussing how passions are caused in
the soul
he says he's got this example of fear so
let's use the fight fight or flight
response as an example he talks about
seeing some strange and terrifying sight
if it's closely related to things that
have previously been harmful to the body
spiders are harmful to the body what
else is harmful to the body what would
scary if I if I brought it to the
classroom right now
what's the classroom like I close the
door and lock it some of the classroom
starts filling up with water
that's scary at first you'd be like but
then you'd be like oh crap we're gonna
drown now why is that scary yeah but
that's very very broad why is water
rising like that scary yeah every one of
you is probably experienced being short
on breath and what it's like to
suffocate a little bit maybe some of you
more than others maybe somebody got
close to drowning at one point you've
been off more than you could chew with
the swimming or they got into some a
closed-off space you know your body
remembers that it remembers a through
your brain and your mind also has that
stored away heart calls the warehouse of
memory right yeah if something scary
happens and it triggers some
associations and your brain says danger
death you know and we aren't afraid of
that so we start feeling the feeling of
fear and it says in some of this this
passion of anxiety is followed by bold
defiance when we talk about the
fight-or-flight response
sometimes we actually fight right if you
feel you're up to the thing you struggle
against it if you feel that you're not
then you get the hell out of there
you panic as except then you're stuck in
a closed room with no exit and the
waters rising it's hard to see where you
gonna run to
but people do it run around feel fear
and terrible things and things happen to
our body like he says with this when we
have the fight-or-flight response I
don't know if you guys know this but
blood flows away from the extremities
because you're getting ready to get cut
and you're getting ready to minimize
love loss your brain your mind is not
doing that your brain is doing your
whole mechanism that is your body
wonderful machine that we have you're
also having adrenaline flow through your
system sometimes people throw up
digestion stops all sorts of things kick
in why it's good not to be panicked all
the time because imagine than happening
to your body constantly wearing out
finishing so nobody Kurt says how does
this happen why does it affect the
different people differently since how
how does the single cause arouse
different passions and different
people's the same impression that the
presence of a terrifying object makes on
the brain and causes fear and some
people may arouse courage and boldness
and others that's because the brains are
not all constituted the same way our
brains are set up somewhat different
from each other depending on what our
experiences are depending on what our
temperaments are depending on what we
actually choose to do can you chain if
you're a kind of fearful person can you
change that through deliberate practices
that you choose through the will how do
you think about things
actually you can choose to do things
like take ten deep breaths and then you
feel less anxious because you're using
your will to do something with your body
which that affects your your mind now
the curtain is an explanation for why we
feel things the way we do as well this
is the main effect of every human
passion is to arouse the soul and make
it will fill the body to move in the way
that passion prepares the body for it
so when you get angry what is what is
your get what is your brain or what is
your mind getting your body ready to do
what are the sort of things that yeah
it's a fight yeah maybe with words maybe
you know with gestures you know we puff
ourselves up watch guys push each other
at the bar you know that's angry
behavior what is your body getting you
ready to do when you feel designed to go
after the thing that you want right what
is your body getting you ready to do
when you feel this this what dickard
calls this basic feeling of amazement
and wonder shut up and pay attention
well your eyes get big you know and you
actually stop doing things now I've been
mentioning this over and over again here
Descartes makes it very clear the soul
can't control the body directly in a lot
of respects you can raise your arm
you can't immediately stop your anger or
make yourself feel joyful or make
yourself stop feeling sadness what you
can do is do this indirectly he says you
can think about things you can bring
certain things into your your
internal vision so to speak you can
imagine things you can choose not to do
certain physical behaviors which then
eventually will make you feel different
ways he says their passions can't be
aroused or suppressed directly by the
action of our will but only indirectly
by our representing to ourselves things
that are usually joined at the passion
we want to have or oppose to the one we
want to thank a lot so if you want to
feel happier the cart would say you need
to think happy thoughts you need to
think to chew you need to choose to
think about things that are actually
happy and not you know sort of tell
yourself that this is nonsense or you
know stupid or things that's already
negative thoughts right those are
judgments about yeah he says it's not
enough to have an abolitionist ourselves
to think about the reasons objects or
precedents that have to do with the
thing in the case of fear if we want to
a less afraid we need to think about the
reasons objects or precedents which
argue that the danger isn't great so you
know when you're afraid of something
here there's a great example how many of
you were shy at one point like in middle
school or high school with respect to
people that you were attracted to you
remember calling people on the phone
that still something people do you like
somebody to call them on the phone talk
with them for a while you don't talk you
like talk about everything else under
the Sun
so many went through do you remember the
first couple times if you're kind of shy
how hard it was actually just a dial the
numbers and then that starts ringing and
you're like what am I gonna do what am I
gonna do you know all this stuff starts
kicking in and then you know after a
while you get a little bit you know more
confident with it when you've done it a
few times in the world hasn't you know
falling apart but you feel that that
sensation of of fear or anxiety now a
manager that you've had a nice uncle or
aunt that was like trying to help you
out and they can see how nervous you
were about this sort of thing and they
said here's what I want you to do just
you know think about this everybody goes
through this when I was your age I had
the same experience and it turned out
okay for me you know you call a few
times don't even don't even worry about
what you're gonna say because people
like get themselves a little - a hope
they don't think I'm stupid you know you
can represent these things to yourself
in such a way as to calm yourself down
and then what's most likely to happen if
you're actually calm and you're not you
know afraid and I can stun it on the
phone and I can say stupid things just
to fill up silent spaces it's probably
gonna be a better conversation and then
you come out of it feeling a bit better
right and all of that is you know this
interaction between mind and body in
terms of passions now he has an
important question here if this is the
case why don't we have full control over
all of our passions all of our feelings
if we can in fact intervene in them why
why don't there's two answers to this so
the first one is pretty pretty simple
there's a lot of crap happening over
here that we don't have any control over
whatsoever
if you got nervous about talking with
somebody that you're attracted to on the
phone there's probably a lot of
different things going on in your mind
that have to do with your experience
that have to do with
temperament you don't have a ton of
control over that sort of stuff
even if you do is sort of exercises to
try to calm yourself down or change your
your habits and behavior it's not a
hundred percent guarantee there's always
going to be stuff sort of impinging on
this side your brain does weird stuff to
it always it always does it always will
your entire life human being is kind of
mysterious so there's the outside what
about the other side how well do we know
our own lines
how much discipline do we actually exert
I mean maybe maybe before today you
never actually had thought that through
my own will I can choose what I'm going
to think about maybe you saw your - from
castle it's going to bounce around from
object to object person to person task
to task you actually have a lot of
control over that but it takes it takes
a long time to develop so you know we
have a lot of issues the other thing
that he brings up we need to have the
right theory if we don't actually
understand what we're doing I'm gonna be
able I've ever taken the machines apart
that you didn't really understand did
you want him to fix that kid I need you
to do that sort of thing then you put it
back together you have scared what we
call spare parts because you couldn't
figure out the pulp everything fit back
in together that's a problem because
sometimes those parts are necessary for
torque that's an example of what the
card says is not having the truth not
having the correct information how many
of you when you when you put things
together to follow the instructions you
notice I don't put my hand up because I
usually I don't follow the instructions
until I get back home I'm done usually
have to backtrack cause I've already
screwed something up so stupid
you know by now I do know that right but
I know it's not a crime they have you
raised your hands the instructions are
actually providing you with the
blueprint for how to do things right
what we need over here is some sort of
set of instructions for how the soul or
the mind works and what we ought to be
willing we even also need some
instructions for our body and our brain
work if we have the wrong theory about
it we're liable to screw things up
partly that gonna be think for example
that falling in love is actually you
know dangerous and could kill you the
way that some people did think about
then we're gonna fear falling in love
and we're gonna like guard everybody
else will follow
you know we can go down the list about
these sorts of things so that's that's
where he leaves off that with part one
part two we're going to go into the
number and types of the basic passions
there's a lot of material there so make
sure to go over it's going to seem kind
of tedious at the first read but then
after the second read you're gonna be
like oh now I see how these things fit
together but this is the basic model
that he's using so you want to keep this
in mind